[Music]
there's another huge event on the way
the annual Victoria's Secret fashion
extravaganza what does it take for a
rising young model to make the show well
we went behind the scenes of a casting
session find out audition rules very
little makeup allowed all the girls must
wear the same black panties and bra plus
stiletto heels smile yes oh yeah sure
what are three must-haves for a
Victoria's Secret model one the strut
you gotta have confidence and attitude
too you need just enough jiggle to be
sexy and three personality plus
discipline well you work out for sure
make sure you drink my water identities
plans for a week which killed me but it
was so worth it I didn't its whole day
hear hear her coming this year the show
is in Paris at the Grand Palais
producers reportedly held off announcing
the location because they were afraid of
being a target there's a lot of security
because it's a high-profile event you
know we have musical artists we have the
models we have an audience we always
have very tight security so she got it
so much yeah last year we saw kendall
Jenner walk the runway and if she
returns it could be her first time back
in Paris since her sister Kim was robbed
other angel faves include Adriana Lima
and Alessandra Ambrosio
of course mrs. Adam Levine viata
Prinsloo and fellow angel Candice
Swanepoel
our brand new moms no word yet if
they'll show off their post baby bots
the most beautiful women ever and had
two amazing babies and hopefully they'll
be back
well those ladies are beautiful with or
without the baby bump right now of
course the show is famous for all of
those wild and daring costumes the
designs and the sketches are already
underway and not a moment too soon I
might add because the Couture outfits
takes months and months to make even
though there's not a lot of material
fair